[Applause]
say
[Applause]
[Music]
i will not tolerate such behavior
if you want to go out go out now but if
you stand again i'll load you up make
your mind up and then shut up and get
out
i warned you'll remember
that they think straw testing curling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
you want me in the future
i know warning of the honorable members
that if they persist in refusing to
comply with my order to withdraw i shall
be contest compelled to name both of
them which may lead to them being
suspended from the house
[Applause]
to ensure that the member complies
what's the names
i order
shut
they'll have a i am now naming you and
kenny mccaskill to leave this chamber so
i just deal with them deal with them
deal with it just sit down
no sergeants and arms escort them out
[Applause]
robin miller
well pretty unruly promises questions
there as you heard two albums were asked
to leave the chamber by the speaker sir
lindsay hoyle and that was for shouting
scotland has a mandate for a referendum
while here on the right of your screen
you can see neil hamby making his way
out him and kenny mccaskill have now
been suspended from the house of commons